[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who's Back in
Black Mirror and this video are breaking
down the final two episodes of season
six due to time constraints I've had to
combine these into one big breakdown but
we've still got lots to talk about in
terms of what happens in them the first
of these is Maisie day which centers
around a member of the paparazzi named
Bo played by zazi beats said in 2006 the
story follows her she tries to take the
first photo of elusive star Maisie day
who hasn't been seen for two weeks now
on the other side of this we have Maisie
herself who's potentially in a lot of
trouble one night she kills someone in a
hit and run and then from here has a
complete breakdown and refuses to go out
in public now Bo doesn't really want to
be involved in the life of being a Pap
anymore but she gets lured back in with
the idea that the follow can be a Golden
Ticket he's got money problems like
everyone else a vicious a bloody vicious
monster of a roommate your bloody
monster and all in all this is basically
her way to a slightly better life and
what this episode is of course gonna be
remembered for is that when bow tracks
down Maisie she turns into a werewolf
comes completely out of nowhere but on a
second watch they do little hints
towards this reveal if you're paying
very close attention now the description
for this episode on Netflix actually has
the first of these clues in it the
streaming service put out two for the
entry and they've gone back and forth
with these depending on when you load
them they say a troubled Hollywood
Starlet goes to great lens to escape a
pack of invasive Paparazzi as she deals
with the aftermath of a hit and run the
second says a troubled Starlet is dogged
by invasive Paparazzi while dealing with
consequences of a hit and run incident
now the keywords here are that the
wolves hunting packs just like the
paparazzi and her being dogged is
reversed when she turns into a dog and
goes after them
bridge
and I genuinely think that this was all
done on purpose it's just not very good
now the hints and Illusions include when
actor just in camley calls both
animal as she drives away I think this
episode is basically meant to ask us who
the monsters are by presenting us with a
literal one that doesn't seem as bad as
the people we follow in the end Bo ends
up initially wanting to help Maisie when
they find her however in the entry
resorts to just wanting to take a photo
of him and what's a moment that will no
doubt make her extremely wealthy
adjusting canley's appearance also ties
this episode into other entries most
notably The Seer Tranquility this is an
in-universe show in which can we start
in and it showed up during nosedive and
also on streamberry and Jonah's awful on
top of this the club in which bone Co
harass the actress outside of is called
Quagmire this is a reference to the club
of the same name that appeared in San
Junipero without potentially being a
recreation of this Californian Outlet
now the character Sydney Alberta gets
arrested and Shout out in the street you
to her sex tape being leaked which has
now made the perhaps think that
anything's fair game she's of course
based off Paris Hilton with Sydney being
changed to Paris to play off the back of
her name her other tenuous Clues
foreshadowing the werewolf come at the
club when we can catch dog paw prints on
the side Mazie also listens to the song
supermassive black hole when she's
driving and this tune appears throughout
the episode this song featured heavily
in the Twilight Saga movies which
themselves also featured werewolves when
Maisie hits the man she initially thinks
it's an animal and then turns around to
see that it's actually a human stuff
like this has been done in a lot of
werewolf media most notably American
Werewolf in London which this episode
riffs on when we get that twist towards
the end when Bo pulls up to the
producer's house we can also see the
moons clearly shot in frame so that it
stands out later on Dr babich also tells
Maisie it's about getting through
tonight and the nights after rather than
getting through the day today honestly
the these are very tenuous like I said
and I thought that the twist was
shocking on the first watch but it kind
kind of came out of nowhere and in the
end I thought this episode was one of
the weaker ones of season six possibly
the worst out of them and unfortunately
I doubt that it's one that I'm gonna go
revisit I get thematically that it's
trying to show how monstrous and feeling
the paparazzi are but I think it should
have probably just stayed and focused on
that I watched a review of the episode
by all mates over at unleash the ghouls
and Connor summed it up by saying that
it should be remembered as the one that
tears down the paths but instead it's
just gonna be remembered as the one
about being about the werewolf which is
a shame as there are some good things
that happen here at thematically Maisie
ends up turning her back on it but at
the end she's drawn back in because the
money outweighs the morals that she
feels she has towards it perhaps also
hunting go after their prey with
complete disregard how they feel about
it and they're much Like the Wolf and
that they're these merciless monsters at
the end Bo just stands there and takes
photos of Maisie and I thought this was
clearly commenting on the death of
Princess Diana and what happened with
the paparazzi in the Parisian tunnel
rather than helping her they just stood
around taking photographs and she died
with camera flashes going off in her
face why I think the Link's there is
because Diana was mentioned earlier in
the season and she took away the press
and publicity from me in a day now I
think that the episodes at its strongest
when it's doing things like that and
Brooker has actually come out over the
weekend and talked about a common
misinterpretation that people have of
the show he said that while a lot of
people think that the show is about how
technology is bad it's actually about
how people are bad and that they'll use
technology in evil ways here the
technology is the camera with Bora
treating behind it in the end and using
it to take photos of Maisie when really
she should be helping this is a shield
which covers her face now so we can't
see who she is and the camera lens is
what she has become several tribes used
to refuse to have their photos taken
because they believe the camera stole
the soul but you have to wonder here
whether this is in regards to Maisie or
it's in fact in regards to Beau she had
a way out but has resorted back to be
the soulless thing that now only cares
about taking the photo it's a great way
to close things out no matter what I
thought of the episode and that also
takes us into demon 79 now if you're
enjoying the video so far we'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe but break down
take this every day now demon 79 was
originally supposed to be released on a
sister series called red mirror which
will deal with more Supernatural things
rather than having it Technology based
according to broker they might end up
doing more red mirror episodes later on
depending on the success of this and let
me know below what you thought in the
episode now there's several nods to
horror classics in this entry with the
score of The Shining being used as the
title comes up we also have the power
step of the entry itself which looks
like it's playing on the one from that
film alongside its ladder sequel titled
doctor sleep made to evoke 70s horror
this entry also tackles themes like race
politics and the incoming Apocalypse at
the hands of nuclear war scented around
a woman named Nita hook I couldn't help
but think this might be a reference to
brooker's real-life wife Connie hook who
has co-wrote several episodes of the
show in the past need a hook could also
be because she needs a hug but might be
a reach now in in the episode she and
wittingly summons a demon named Gap who
tells her that she has to get three
subscribers before Mayday otherwise the
world will end originally conceived to
be a punk figure Brooke has said that he
was making a playlist of 70 songs and
realized that the male singer of Boney M
would be much more striking you could
say she needs a Boney M from Daddy Cool
now after the title reveal we come
across Anita and can hear Bright Eyes in
the background by Art Garfunkel this was
written for the 1978 movie Watership
Down and the song itself is about a
dream like state where someone goes on a
journey this is similar to neither in
the entry and they give a lot of focus
to her eyes being wide open at several
points this happens when she sees the
visions and they show her the apocalypse
and also the darkest parts of the people
that she's going after in the animated
movie The Rabbit set their eyes open to
how horrific the world is and this is
also something that neither experiences
too now the episode is packed with a
number of different Easter eggs and ties
back to other episodes from the often
throughout there's a shoe brand called
wealthy's Footwear which might be
building off the back of Maisie day you
also see a newspaper clipping and this
talks about how a typically Publican
named Robert Daly has died Robert Daly
is a name that's appeared in the series
before and this was the character that
Jesse plemons played in the USS
Callister this is probably directed Toby
Haynes giving himself a bit of a shout
out as he directed not only this but
also that episode as well the Talisman
used to summon the demon also seems like
a thinner version of the white bear
symbol which actually appears later on
in the flashes of Michael smart speaker
typically has been mentioned in the
season already and during lock Henry we
learned that there was a bat to
nominated documentary centered around
the town Michael Smart's name also
appeared in a new paper clipping during
that and the scene we get later on shows
several other things from the series
revolving around him the fictional ukm
broadcaster from the universe announces
his Britannia party and we learned that
smart actually took power from Michael
callow however the flash ears shows that
he was kicked out for his racist remark
blocks in a clipping and lock Henry's
show that he'd rebuked this it then
announced that he started a new party
which leads into the Britannia one who
has a Union Jack in the white bear
symbol there's also a shot of facial
recognition and this could indicate that
the ADI is from hate and the nation came
from Smart we also see one of the dogs
from Metalhead and in use ticker and
lock Henry confirmed that they were
introduced by smart the episode features
him being part of the Tory party and
also the national front who came to
prominence during that decade NF is
spray-painted on Nita's door at one
point in her racist co-workers represent
how the ideals have seeped into the
population unemployment and inflation
are an all-time high and people are now
looking for someone they can blame
smarts are more weaponizes the hatred
that they use to push their agendas as
he says they'll never get in power so
people should just vote for him instead
though gab is thought to be the titular
demon of the episode I definitely see it
as smart and Hell doesn't even want him
dead because of all the evil he can do
smart represents the control of the
weak-minded people who are easily swayed
by politicians and he somewhat
hypnotizes Nita's co-worker into voting
for him eventually Gap is also a
real-life demon from The Infernal
dictionary that has shape-shifting
abilities and can show people the past
let's say real life depends on what you
believe but he states that he's a
misfape which is a lower class demon
it's also the fears of nuclear war which
were prominent at the time and this is
the form that the apocalypse takes his
time around Anita wrestles back and
forth with whether this is actually real
or if she's going crazy no one other
than her can see the demon and they also
give lip service to her mother being
thought of being crazy too potentially
need is experiencing the same thing and
we know that she has hallucinations of
attacking her co-workers and customers
which don't turn out to be real at one
point Nina reads the book creative
visualizations which is about using the
power of imagination to create what you
want in life Eda is clearly attracted to
the singer of Boney M and this is why
Gap takes in his form come the end of
the entry the paragraph together to
spend eternity in Oblivion which he
early describes the sounding like how
her life is now so if you take this as
all being in her mind then you could see
this as her Imagining the life she wants
to have with the man she loves now her
murder spree is somewhat foreshadowed by
the newspaper articles that she finds in
the basement there's a clipping about
Jeffrey posit and then she comes across
others recounting three deaths in the
area the final clipping shows at the
MayDay celebrations of being a grand
success showing that posit likely went
through a similar thing to what needed
it too the third article about the
woman's disappearance also talks about
callow stepping down from his seat which
could be a nod to Michael callow
vacating his position the timelines are
off but I think there are connections
there if you want to see them now later
on we meet detective Fisher and can
catch him reading the books Smiley's
people dropping in 1979 this book
featured characters that were later
brought across into the movie Tinker
Tail as Soldier Spy the cover also has
Dominoes on it which is the form that
the Talisman takes later on when Nita is
taken by the police neither ends up
killing people or seen as being some of
the worst in society with her take
taking down a father that abuses his
daughter and a man that got away with
murder however she is spotted by the
letters flatmate slash brother and she
kills him in what's one of the most
awkward hammer or knife fights that I've
ever seen this should be the three
murders done but the Talisman demands
more blood and this Gap Rings 666 in
order to speak to his bosses turns out
that murderers can't count as people who
have killed you them already being
damned and this she then has to go after
Smart in the end though she's cool
before this can happen and seemingly
escapes the apocalypse to spend eternity
with gap Now The more I've thought about
it the more I think this didn't really
happen the way Nita thinks it did the
book is a major clue when we have the
history with her mother adding to it as
well we know from the other entries that
Michael smart survived and he might have
even weaponized this attack to push his
name out of the Forefront though the
connections yet they can often be
tenuous in the show I think the timeline
messes up if you count this as Canon so
I just think it's in her head I have
seen that this is actually an
in-universe movie but yeah either way to
me it's all made up now you also have
the similar authorities to the Son of
Sam killings which too took place in the
70s David berkowich said that a demon in
the form of a dog told him to do it and
though he's admitted this was a hoax it
could be the basis for this episode
that's what I kind of took from it
anyway and hopefully you've enjoyed us
going through these episodes in the
series I think the first two are great
but unfortunately it kind of fell off
around there and no I enjoyed three I
think the season got worse so longer it
went on it was still better than season
five to be fair and I thought this
episode was better than Maisy day but
yeah this season definitely had its
highs and also its lows I still enjoyed
going through it though and I did want
to do this as two separate videos
initially but yeah like I said time got
the better of me now we have a pretty
packed week and I will be back with a
breakdown on secret Invasion come
Thursday and then one and from season 2
which will be dropping next week was
lucky enough to see the finale of that
and yeah we have a lot to talk about
with it so make sure you stick around
anyway let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below and if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button and you'll get asked access to
early videos we also have our merch
store over at shop zeroedition.com which
sells lots of nerdy inspired t-shirts
had some more you want something else to
watch you've got a Black Mirror video on
screen right now and hopefully I see you
over there right after this by the way
huge thank you for sticking through the
video I've been Paul and I'll see you
next time you take care peace